[Music]
Runk Oxnard California be there in a few
weeks uh get your tickets now they're
roll they're getting scooped up
Sacramento California Brea California
got a lot of California dates here
Phoenix Arizona I'm coming back baby I
love Phoenix Arizona El Paso Texas
Albuquerque New Mexico and some other
dates uh that are about to uh pop off
live here soon and you can get the
special if you haven't seen it yet grow
or die
at chia.com uh it was uh it's been great
and if you haven't seen it what are you
doing going over to chia.com and get
that special and check it out don't be
the only one left out um and uh there's
also uh actually the new merch is cool
from grow or die this is it grow or die
there you go that shirt nice little
looks like the color is stone or some
something you know
nice if you got blue eyes it really pops
with it I don't but you know I'm still
secure um so anyway chris.com and a lot
of other cool merch but uh without
further Ado this is the next episode of
[Music]
congratulations here we go there we
go um we you know if you are what you
saying you are
you're a
superstar I don't know dude you um how
do you get a song stuck in your head if
you didn't hear it I didn't hear it and
that was just what popped in my head and
I didn't hear it so go figure oh man
here we are dude here we
are well I'll tell you it's already too
hot in this room I I don't know how when
they made this room in this house they
didn't put the air thing on it but it's
all good it is what it
is um I got back from um Philadelphia
and
reading which was uh in
Pennsylvania loving it uh I don't know
the
uh the um Philadelphia is they had this
like it was it first of all it was
raining the whole time Philadelphia's
cool it's one of those places that's
just too focused on the sports although
during Christmas time you know what it
is dude they're too focused on whatever
is going on the Christmas time was
Bonkers there they were just it was
there was
Santa right outside I was staying at my
hotel right outside there was like this
Square where you could go it was
actually really really cool you they
built these like Huts out there and you
could like go by candles and everything
that like wives and moms like and you
can go get food like croissants and [__]
and you can go go get like you can go
probably Santa was there there was a
carousel it was just crazy and it was so
packed and I was about oh and an ice
skating rink and then I went to uh and
then there was the Grinch there I
thought it was a statue one of those
guys that does
this and then if you give him a dollar
he'll go oh H and I was like oh that's
not a statue that's a guy and I put
money in his thing like a like a like a
lone guy it was just me and I was like I
got to get a video for Calvin and and I
and I put the tip in and he goes oh hey
and then I was holding the the video and
he thought I was taking a picture so he
was trying to stay still I'm like no
dude I put the thing in there so you'd
move and now you're staying still
because you think it's a picture it's a
video it was a debacle honestly but it
it was fine it was
also the makeup was amazing bro I've
been watching this show on Netflix
called face off and here's the deal dude
I don't know um why they put only Ser
some seasons on on on streaming services
I guess it's just to like pimp out the
show a little bit to see if we like it
and then we go find the show where it is
originally like it's on peacock it's
called face off and it's a bunch of
Hollywood makeup artists well it's a
bunch of makeup artists that want to get
into Hollywood um and they'll do things
like you
know anywhere from like Miss Doubtfire
makeup to like Braveheart where he just
paints a little blue on them and um and
it's like they Vibe for the winner to be
the winner and it's I didn't even know
that like how's this show been on for
for uh nine Seasons or or like how many
seasons is face off how many
seasons is face
off
13 13
Seasons
Seasons yeah oh sorry
11 no 13 how's something been on 13
Seasons I don't know what the [__] it is
until now do you understand 13 years and
it's on the Sci-Fi channel Channel but
okay but still it's also on peacock so
anyway I watched it on on
um uh on Netflix and I and it's was like
trending number four or whatever and I
was like all right all right I'll check
it
out I'm not really into you know but
we'll see maybe someone could do
something cool with like a a devil or a
grinch we we'll check it out bro that
[__] sucked me in and it and it's it's
like a hypnotizing show dude it's like a
it's like a Mindless show that you can
those are the best shows aren't they
where you don't really have to pay
attention you can just turn them on at
3:30
p.m. and it's on and you kind of know
what's going
on and you're just like oh like I don't
like reality TV and I don't really like
competition shows but boy is this that
and boy am I sucked in I'm a
housewife can't turn a hoe into a
housewife but you can turn a [__]
comedian male into a housewife
apparently because I just watched that
show dude and they only had two seasons
on Netflix and I go oh man I thought it
was seasons one and two it's not it's
like seasons 5 and seven and I go oh
dude where where's the I'm buying the go
take me to iTunes then found out it was
on peacock oh guess who's got a peacock
prescription me I got a peacock
subscription peacock prescription like
I'm a vet peacock
subscription and so now I'd be watching
it so much dude and it's mindless and me
and my wife we watch that
dude
oh God what's in my mouth
plastic um and uh so I watched that and
um anyway that's you know it is what it
is I got sucked in and now I watch it on
peacock and that's my life dude
okay and my friend was like are you
going to download it when you go on the
plane and I was like no dude I'm on my
Supernatural [__] because I'm watching
Supernatural and Supernatural continues
to be the absolute worst show I've ever
scene and I watch it and it's mindless
and it's terrible and it's always green
everything every shade is green why do
they do that
dude why do they make movies
like like Minority Report is blue only
blue even Tom Cruz is like a little bit
of a shade of blue it's all blue why do
they do that I didn't realize they do it
so much that movie Whiplash is all
yellow hit is so yellow it's about
[__] that song is about the movie
Whiplash and a whiplash is going to come
out in a few years and it's all yellow
the
worst rendition of that song bro when I
first heard that song Yellow I go like
this oh life's different now because I
love it and I and I and I I thought dude
my friend said it was a masterpiece
after he heard it the first time I laugh
so hard I started crying I was laughing
so hard but it is I'll be damn it is a
good show a movie uh song wow what am I
fog horn
leorn um anyway I watch face off I watch
Supernatural on the plane
dude God it's so [__] ridiculous that
show talk about a show that's been on
that's been on for like 19 seasons and
they'll just be like uh
uh you know what Sam will just be like
well Dad Dad didn't respect me and then
Dean will just be like well he checked
up on you you just didn't know about it
and Sam's like why didn't you tell me
and then Dean would just be like it's a
two-way street buddy why don't you call
him you know and I'm just like
okay that's actually kind of you know I
don't like that's the thing I don't like
about the show though it's like just
fight the vampires find the
[__] first of all it says it's
get it says it's it says what's his name
Jeffrey Dean Stanton what's a guy he's
he's a regular on the show dude he's
been only on one scene in the beginning
he the guy's getting paid out the
[__] anus dude he's just getting
getting paid out the anus just just
chilling God that's the job man remember
when Network TV you just get I don't
know if it's like that anymore but my
God you just get paid like 50 G's just
to be oh God they be like we don't need
you today just getting 50 just getting
[__] five
racks sitting in a
trailer I don't know I'm I'm I'm I'm
this is just the beginning of the
podcast I'm I'm bumbling around but it's
just
like Michael B Jordan crashed his
[__]
Ferrari he crashed his Ferrari into his
blue Ferrari into a blue like Kia or
something and just got out you
know that's a beautiful car he crashed
his Ferrari and he just got out and the
cops were like what happened and he's
like I'm not saying [__] and that is
awesome
dude that's what I want to do if I like
cuz my friend was like oh I can't
believe he didn't say anything to the
cops he didn't even offer an explanation
I was like dude that happens mum's a
word for me if that happens to me all of
a sudden oh I must be [__] I'm I'm
I'm kindor Reeves with his mouth when
his mouth gets all covered in The Matrix
you ain't hearing [__]
dude I see all those [__] [__]
confessions that they coers and they
make you do it that would that would
work on me straight up if I was drunk
driving and because you're drunk already
and then you crash and you're like hey
what's going on here and you're
you're trying to play it off just don't
say [__] but you want to because you're
drunk and just be like yeah everything
is fine you know we just came we were
playing we're coming from uh the hills
it's all good and they're like all right
turn around spread
them what for if you don't say
[__] refuse a breathalizer [__] yeah let
that blood alcohol content lower as
you're driving off to the
station how do I know man the Frank do
IO I need to I'm I'm you know it's like
I'm so happy I'm home I'm home for a
while and I got I came home and Calvin
gave me a big
hug that feels so good dude part of me
just doesn't I I now that I'm a dad of
two H I missed my I missed my family so
much on the
road you know FaceTiming and
[__] but bro if you think for a second
for one
second that I didn't eat three
[__] if I did that I didn't eat a
club sandwich every single night at The
Ritz Carlton at 1:00 a.m. because they
had room service 24 hours a day if you
think I didn't eat that with the [__]
AV dude they had guacamole salsa on it
if you think for one second dude they
had white cheddar cheese on it if you
think for one second Chris missed that
opportunity well dude check me out
eating
[__] a a turkey club 1:00 a.m. at the
[__] richz Carlton in Philadelphia
[Music]
dude I don't know
man I got all new material and I'm happy
with
it I talk about rehab in there and one
of the guys from rehab came to my show
in
Reading with his
wife and I was like talking about him on
stage obviously I didn't use his name I
was just like oh for [__]
sake this is this is crazy dicey I was
sweating but then afterwards he was like
bro that was so funny I was like thank
God thank
God what's going on in the
world right
here
not
now oh dude somebody threw something to
Florence Pew's face
o God I hate that is her name Florence
Pew that's like if it smells bad um
where you where's your favorite place in
Italy Florence Florence
Pew um dude it's a uh I've been thrown
something on stage once twice I've been
thrown a flyer to another comedy show
disrespectful and a pencil the pencil
hit me in the shoulder the flyer cut my
nose it was Gambit it was it must have
been Gambit dude they just go and it
goes and I go what the
[__] who the [__] these derel dude you
know what it is you know what it is it's
in the crowd they don't they know they
can't be seen this this is basically a
[__]
online just just anonymously
throwing oh right in her [__]
eye god dude everyone hates Hollywood
anyway I was on the
um I was on the I was on the
plane and wait a minute Young Thug is is
is on trial
oh Young Thug I was thinking of uh who's
that other dude yeah yeah you know what
I [__] was thinking about this the
other day yeah I know he's on trial
Robie Young Thug's racketeering trials
began with Georgia Park accusing him of
being gang I love how rappers will get
in
um law trouble and everyone will just be
like free
him no free him you could to kill nine
people free him free Bobby schur they
say free Bobby schur they [__] didn't
he kill someone they're like yeah free
free Tory Lanes you shot someone's foot
free him why cuz they rap That's crazy
dude if a comedian gets merely a whiff
of an accusation people are like oh dude
kill him stab him laser beam him to
death um and the Atlanta rapper was
accused of co-founding a violent street
gang in his co-founding a violent street
gang in his hometown prosecut using to
critically Acclaim performers own lri
evidence against that's crazy to me dude
it's art
that's crazy although rappers be brazing
as [__]
though he's been in jail since May
wow
[__] that is
crazy we didn't chase any of the lyrics
to solve any murders he's the law
enforcement CH the murders and found the
lyrics I mean I guess but every rapper
talks about killing [__] that's
what rap
is what's that whole thing I murder
everything moving Jay-Z said lock them
up I ain't even have to use my AK today
was a good day okay today you're free
all the other days lock them up Ice
Cube what about [__] uh lock up IC
tea dude lock them all up lock up
exhibit for [__] making p my
ride lock up Eminem for killing his
right didn't he have a [__] he not
every other song is about kidnapping his
fiance lock him
up or or or well you know although there
was that one song by R Kelly when he was
like I did it I made it or whatever it
was like don't yo bro you're really
pushing it you
know cuz these R well also what what
also also what is a young thug lyric can
I can't understand I'm a 43-year-old
dude but I I don't know what he's
saying [__] I'm so old he sounds
underwater look uh your prosecution your
honor I'd actually like to uh put this
song wait you know what honestly here
young thug thug
songs
wow the the names of the songs I I I'd
like
to I'd like to exhibit a the song oh you
went a basic
um here we go well let's play it play
it y there we go and lock them
up I I don't know I'm I'm an old guy now
I really am rappers all sound the same
to me I'm an old
guy
um about this [__]
[__] you
cried I'm not a coward and I'm not a
liar you
cried there were tears that ran down my
face but I did not cry
ah I mean that's
crying I'm not a coward and I'm not a
liar you
cried there were tears that ran down my
face but I did not cry I mean that's
crying that's the most manly [__]
dude that is I'm not a coward and I'm
not a liar you cried there were tears
running down my face but I did not cry
that's crying
nope you painted the
house
uh there was paint in the bucket I used
the brush I put the brush in the bucket
and then I spread it all over the house
but I did not paint the
[Laughter]
house you know you dance at the
party
I was at the house with many people
there there was music playing and I did
move to the beat but I was not
dancing you
danced there were tears that ran down my
dude the fact that Andrew Tate just
is
so ready to just talk so loud and bite
someone's face
off
oh wow people are said
this look at the he also claims he's not
bald and then someone says I'm not bald
there's skin running up my scalp but I'm
not
bald um but that you know what dude
honestly those are the times we live in
those are the times we live in like cuz
he you can just straight be like I'm not
crying I remember there's a joke that uh
what what was his name um Frank Kendo
had about uh uh Bill Clinton and he was
just like Bill Clinton lies so much you
know all politicians lie but he was like
Bill Clinton will lie so much he'll just
be like I am not here and dude you that
was funny back then now you could do
that Trump could be like I'm not here
and trumpers will be like I don't
[__] see
him prove it you can just do
that I think that that's so wild
I mean dude we don't know what's real
and what's not anymore have you seen the
AI
model itana or whatever it sounds like a
[__] I mean how much is this the
people who made her like love Mortal
Kombat aana
wins here it is
itana woman is Spain's hottest model but
she's not real so Spanish to to like do
the reason they did it is so Spanish and
this is the best so she's got pink first
of all yeah of course she's slamming
she's fake but let me tell you this dude
all right look with TSO pink hair feline
eyes and a prominent deage I don't know
what that is Aton Lopez 25 is the kind
of model who could sell anything all
right y y she has about 200,000
followers and she was invented okay now
my my buddy sent me the picture of her
and he was like look how hot this chick
is and I looked at her and the first
thing I thought was she's
fake it's still not good enough yeah it
does look good but but like if you're
the kind of guy that like and also she's
still fake everyone knows she's fake and
she's still selling stuff like she's
still promoting she she makes like two
thou she whoever these [__] you know
Spaniards are that made her makes two
grand like a shout out or whatever and
she's not even real Anita Lopez here's
the thing the reason why they did it the
quote was we did it we so we could this
was my favorite we did it so that we
could make a better living and not be
dependent on other people who have egos
who have Manas or who just want to make
lot of money by posing dude that is so
awesome these
Instagram hios are about to have a rude
awakening with no one straight up no one
is you know who's going to replace you
you know how you oh dude you're gonna
get replaced oh don't have a bad
attitude they'll drop you in a second to
hire someone else oh yeah dude now
they'll just drop you in a second and
replace you with no one Anita Lopez
itana Lopez she's not real dude I love
that oh dude people who have
attitudes the [__] out I can't deal with
Attitude
peoples I can't deal
it also you know how easy it is to be a
[__] model nowadays get a get you
used to have to go through like uh
agencies and [__] like that now you
could just build your own following it's
almost as easy as being a [__]
passable comedian nowadays oh my God
there's so many trash comedians I can't
even [__] believe it if I see another
person who's done standup for three
years it's like my specials coming out
in 2 weeks I'm going to [__] become
I'm going to drive for ups
dude did you know how many times I I'm
like I don't know if that joke's good
enough I don't know if I should do that
should I put that out and you got people
out there hey where you from oh yeah oh
you're a teacher oh yeah
whoa he's all like I'm a
teacher and they like oh I just dude
this whole wave of stand I I don't even
know if I'll do honestly let me be
honest with you I put out my special I
made a [__] lot of money on my
special doing it my way that's great and
it's great that I made money on it I
have money dude I may not even do
another special I because it's so quick
and the turnaround is
so it's like I see other comedians put
stuff out and it's like oh they're
talking about the thing that just
happened a month ago it's like by a year
from now I do this bit and I've been
working on it for a
here like like I did this joke about the
um the Spider-Man meme where I was like
my my it's in grow or die I was talk
about how my these people are I I say
these three people are looking at each
other it's like that Spider-Man meme
dude I've been doing that since like
that Meme came out and now I heard it's
out on my grower die and I've been doing
it for two years but like there's people
who are doing that joke now and it's
like I don't think they stole it or I
don't you know I don't know if they saw
me do it and then [__] did it
themselves but it's like like it's kind
of not the hardest thing to think of you
know obviously they probably aren't
doing it the same way I'm doing it but
it's like oh you gotta [__] let this
[__] be out it's like you're trying to
beat everyone to the punch and that's
what that's what I don't like about
uh I don't know man I I feel like these
jokes need you need time to like do it
but I guess that's not the [__] thing
anymore I'm the old guy talking now
because it's like that's why I used to
get annoyed with Twitter when I would
tweet it's like people are just like
they wait for somebody to die just to
make a joke about it on Twitter and it's
like all right dude you got your [__]
nine followers from it it was sad that
the person died though how about and how
about just chill and this is a first
draft joke it just happened but then
people became millionaires off the [__]
so it's like okay you got people sitting
in seats because of
this I don't know man but anyway it's
easy to become a [__]
model models really took it into their
own uh hands though didn't they we
realized how everyone like how how we
realized how the real people like curvy
women and [__] you know like remember
when mods used to be all like remember
when Jen Aniston was like it dude if
Instagram was around back then Jen
Aniston would have been treated like
Taylor Swift by people who are like oh
dude she has no butt she's [__] this
and that she's
mid all the friends cast would be Latino
you
know it'd be like [__] it wouldn't be
Jennifer it would be like um
yenifer what's the [__] Monica it
would be
Monique you
know Chandler would be
teso hey what's up I'm back Joey comes
in whoa
[Laughter]
dog
Jose it would be [__] and and and
everyone would be thick as
[__] although what's her name was hot
um Monica Courtney
Cox yeah she was and you know I'm not
taking anything away from Jenna Aniston
and and and and and Lisa kud was was
good looking it's
just
yeah we really got exposed by liking
them thick thick you know cuz Instagram
is like you just
got
oh I dud I always think about this
Disneyland and how expensive it
is this is crazy
dude what I here's what I don't get
about
PR
like Nick Cannon say this is the
headline Nick tannan says he probably
spends $200,000 a year taking his 12
kids to Disneyland first of
all it's too many kids okay but second
of all if you have 12 kids you go to
Disneyland we know cuz Disneyland it
costs $25 for a
Coca-Cola
um so but what I here's what I don't get
because this is in People magazine I
know Nick Canon is a star and has been a
star for a long
time um but honestly why is this in the
[__] any
news that's what I don't get like I
don't understand why so he look he
appeared at The Breakfast Club show
Friday this is how it happened told the
host that he goes to Disneyland at least
once a month to celebrate special
occasion kids lives between birthday
holiday you know how much money I spent
in Disney that year um a lot he
confirmed by saying to move around
Disney like I'm probably spending
$200,000 a year at Disneyland okay so
first of all he said probably which
means it's a he doesn't know second of
all this is in People
magazine do people I mean I'm clicking
on this because it's
ridiculous are people like is a PR
person being like hey we got to get this
in the the news cuz like crazy [__]
happens to stars that nobody reports on
and and why is this in
it you know what I'm
saying
he has 12 kids
dude that's
fantastic I love that I love uh I love
Nick Cannon I love that he has 12 kids
dude that's so
awesome I I would do that if I had
never-ending
money um I would have so many kids and
all my haters would be like oh no I'd be
like do we don't I'd be like Babas kids
we don't die we
multiply I don't understand the people
like Nikki Hil like here's another one
Nikki Hilton admits motherhood
definitely changed her bond with sister
Paris Hilton dude first of all like I
guess that's PR right because who the
[__] and I don't mean this is a
disrespect
like they're great I those women I don't
know that at all they they they do good
[__] maybe I don't know I don't [__]
know I don't know I'm talking to my ass
no knock on them but who the [__] even
cares about what Paris Hilton is doing
right now and she was the famous
one I don't even I don't even remember
there's a Nikki Hilton oh okay oh yeah
there's n Hil so that changed motherhood
and definitely changed her bond with
sister Paris who gives a [__] I I don't
understand
this here's another one Mindy King
visits NYC with kids for
Thanksgiving who gives a
[__] who's clicking on
that look at this here's another one
Jessica Simpson feels like she's it's
all people that [__] used to be
famous look at this one Gregory
pek look at this one Julius Caesar sh
went shopping at Lowe's look at this
this unbelievable holy [__] Jessica
Simpson feels like she already had
Christmas after her kids put up holiday
tree early dude I saw
what do something about Ryan Reynolds at
least or Tyler Swift here's another one
mcau culin steps out with both sons for
first time at Hollywood walking okay he
got the Hollywood Walk okay fine and
it's Christmas okay cuz at home alone
okay but M everyone here used to be
famous does people report on anybody
that
[__] this is crazy bro
look at that oh bro I'm losing my mind
Paris here's another one this is all on
people parison spends $700 at Party City
hours before Sun Phoenix birth to
decorate delivery Suite I get a
[__] who's this look at this another one
gwenneth PTO shares her most recent
pictures she not she not [__] famous
anymore who gives a [__] what the [__]
is people doing what dude is this issue
in
2001 this is Nast
oh my god dude another one about Jessica
Simpson
dude Jessica Simpson husband says her
Jessica Simpson says her husband and
kids miss her as she splits time between
like I no [__] what is no [__] weekly
bro what this is oh my oh my God another
one dude Kat Von D's renovation who
looking thinks about these people
anymore
wow
bro what what what I got it wait a
minute dude I got to be like that in
[__] three years people will probably
be like oh Chris Lee used to be famous I
can't wait to get people
[__] Chrystal Chrystal Leah walked
around a [__] Ralph's grocery store
with cargo shorts
on oh I can't wait for
that yo gr Grand Theft Auto
trust trust hold on so all
right Grand Theft Auto coming out we'll
probably get flagged for this
huh yeah I can't play it Grand Theft
Auto trailer came out Grand Theft Auto
is oh yeah because there's a song on it
by Tom
Petty came out
bro this trailer came out
five hours
ago it
has
33 million
views
oh my they don't even make the game
anymore they make the ad Revenue off
that they just made [__] 20 mil off
of this YouTube
video oh my god
dude look at this somebody that
commented we've waited 10 years for this
moment and it's finally here dude it's
not coming out till
2025 that is
crazy what it here look I'm going
through it it it looks cool but these
are all cutcenes right and no they're
not they they show
gameplay this is oh I'll turn it low
then so I can watch
it
oh get through this all right we can do
is byck all right we'll do this on the
patreon and yeah [__] it it looks so
badass I'll go I'll get it I'll play it
for a day
dude it is crazy how many views this
[__]
gets God is it my Miami is that what it
is Miami's different
huh is it in Miami I don't know but like
let's just talk about Miami Miami is
just different huh you could go into
Miami and like you could go to Miami and
get
HIV and you know what I mean like the
most Miami [__] would be like going to
Miami getting HIV and either having it
turned into full-blown AIDS and dying
within a year or just live with HIV for
decades in Miami you know what I mean
both of those things are the most Miami
[__] and you could do
that you could do that in Miami you know
what I'm talking about and just have the
time of your life like dude the guy got
shot what was the Versace was that the
guy who got shot outside in Miami he
just went outside to get the paper and
he just Pap Pap somebody Pap right that
that gay dude just P to Versace and he
just [__] died and Versace was just
like bro that's Miami that was probably
his last last word was probably like
that's Miami dude and by the way also
everyone's gay in Miami they don't give
a [__] they don't give a [__] you're gay
in Miami and that's fine but like you go
to Miami Miami is like prison you go
there for too long you just start
[__] dudes you just start letting it
happen because who gives a [__] Miami is
so crazy and the dudes there are short
and wide as [__] because there is always
a festival in Miami and it's Miami why
do you even need a festival in Miami
like how many times a year does somebody
say dude meet me at Art basil I I don't
know when the [__] art basil is but it's
every [__] two weeks or they have
Ultra Miami is just [__] crazy
different and it's so hot and it'll rain
so hard for 19 minutes and then stop
like it changed its mind the weather
just goes you know what no [__]
it you don't have my consent to keep
raining that's what Miami does and then
the weather goes oh I'm so sorry and
then they say well let's just have
another
festival Miami is crazy
dude we all need to live in Miami and
just I need to start
snorting crazy
fenel just dis
stilled and the sunset's godamn it you
know what I need to get super [__]
tan I am so sick of being so translucent
I'll tell you what man I'm going to get
tan you know what mark my [__] words
I'm going to get tan it's December I'm
gonna get
tan and uh I'm gonna get
tan and I'm gonna have a [__] great
time being tan
dude
I don't know man I I don't know if I
could it's hot as [__] in here
um I was at arow one the other day and
it was just like I was with the family
it was really nice you know we got some
chicken for $57 and aroan is just like
aroan has a now has a a a they did a
collaboration with Balenciaga and it's
like all right dude I you know aroan
Balenciaga hat that just says aroan
Balenciaga and it's like
$27,000 and then they have uh uh like a
shirt that just says aroan Balenciaga
and it's
$650 and it's just like
dude and people I see this [__] on
Instagram people comment under it holy
[__] that's a
lit and I'm like all right man
Cuda but anyway I'm there and we're
chilling bro there's like nine Russians
that hang out of the aroan that just sit
and smoke and have like do gabana
sunglasses on no matter what the weather
and like they have the tight shirts
where their [__] bellies are coming
out I what is it with Armenian and
Russian [__] where they just
will put on a shirt and then gain the
weight it's like that's what it's like
it's like they're just like and N I
don't change my shirt dog n n not till
it
rips and it's like a [__] um fendy
shirt you
know or a or a or a and and and and it
just like will smoke outside of a
[__]
patio and they're not they don't say
[__] to each
other and they got crazy jewelry on but
there was one of the dudes that just was
there by himself they usually like nine
of them there and he was by himself I'm
with my family and he's there um and
he's next to us just pick you know what
he's doing picking a ringtone hey guy do
that in the car and he would or put
[__] beats in the [__] was
likeing binging bing bang
bang and my even my son was like what's
that guy
doing and I'm like bro you're annoying a
three-year-old how do you do
that you can't annoy a three-year-old
they just laugh you don't get annoyed
until you're like [__] 171
18 this dude in the [__] tight fendy
shirt was
just no not that one
cypo no not that
one no not that
one Billy's crying a lot over there I
hear him out there he's crying Billy's
seven months he's
crawling barely he's almost crawling
he's like moving he's doing that Army
walk like somebody shot his
friend um and he's trying to go get him
ducking um sorry guys I had to go to the
bathroom um
anyway yeah let's see what's up with
this stuff God that's so cute man kids
just keep he just keeps getting cute
when does it you as a father you're just
like you're just like oh uh you have
your first kid and then you're like oh
this is as good as it's ever going to
get and then like 3 weeks later you're
like no actually who hold on he just
looked in my eyes this is just because
it's ever going to get and then he
starts crawling like oh this is the best
ever get and then it starts uh uh uh
walking like this going best ever get
and then he starts like wanting to go
see a movie you're like oh this is going
to be the best ever get and then you're
like oh it's just every day is better
and better dude I am blessed and it's
awesome and now Billy is starting to
crawl and it's just the sweetest
sweetest thing dude I know this a comedy
podcast I don't always want to do comedy
bro you know but uh yeah I'm blessed man
I'm very thankful for my life um but
let's go into uh
yeah so let me ask you a question about
this George Santos [__] I know he's
expelled from Congress everybody
does all of the bad things when you're
at that level so
Su they [__] pick and choose
willy-nilly [__] it's unbelievable like
Trump had the documents at his house
every other president always took
documents and [__] that's just if you're
the
president and you're not taking doc
documents home you're not really being
the president dude I want a president
that takes the work home with him
documents and all I want secret dossier
I want all sorts of [__] I want the I
want I want I want my president to take
documents home dude because I want him
to do I want him to have homework
because he's the
president I want him to have the
documents on him when he's playing golf
every president plays [__] golf I
want to except for Joe Biden cuz he
would fall the [__] down but
but uh did you see about the thing when
he was saying to uh Joe Biden when Joe
Biden was with the the little girl and
he was like how old are you and and she
and she was like how old do you think he
was like 17 she was like and the mom was
like she's
six you saw that K not the president
anymore dude you make a mistake like
that not the president anymore a
six-year-old looks like only a
six-year-old um but yeah I don't it's so
weird how like this [__] happens with
political figures because hey they all
do it they all do it it's hard even to
believe in a democracy and I don't mean
to
[__] turn into right Chris but it's
hard even to believe in a democracy when
you know there's [__] behind the scenes
we don't know stuff that the
government's doing and I'm not even
saying that we should I don't even give
a [__] we're never going to know all
this [__] so
the whole do your own research [__] I'm
just like I have no idea what what is it
you can do confirmation bias if I really
wanted to look into Joe Biden being a
lizard I could probably find some [__]
where I'd be like oh man maybe he does
go into the ocean and shed his skin it's
out
there ah let's do some of this here um
ELO gret and Dugan truest baby sending
you Elder pin
now Tai G plays golf like the cops are
after him to Liz from will in Portland
happy 10th wedding anniversary uh go to
my uh holler do what is it get get your
a shout out or ads whatever at holler.
bab christalia and there you go um is
Billy ish
gay um Billy Alish came out as gay God
you know what I I I I it's I I the fact
that it's
new news to come out and be like
sexuality should straight up just be
nobody's business
period or or everyone's business if we
didn't give a [__] but people do give a
[__] obviously
so um also we know she's gay you know
she's too successful and Poppy to not be
gay at this point everyone's got to be
gay you you can not be gay if you're a
pop singer
what' she say
though like no we love her out of that
reception field did your has your mind
changed a little bit I'm still scared of
them but I think they're
pretty he's double what the [__] is this
why did it and then espresso ad pop up
in the middle of it George clone in his
[__] espresso ads it's like come off
it dude guy's got8 trillion do um so
Billy Alis confirmed that she recently
came out we know you know you you can't
not be like they're all
gay
wait she revealed she didn't intend to
make a grand gester of coming out no I
didn't iish said but I kind of thought
wasn't it obvious I didn't realize
people didn't know I just don't really
believe in it I'm just like why can't we
just exist agree I've been doing this
for a long time and I just didn't talk
about it whoops agree dude Billy Alice
you got a new fan [__] yeah she's my
favorite artist dude because not because
she does lesie [__] but because she
doesn't give a [__] I you know you you
know how much I wish I was gay so I
could just be like oh yeah oh dude you
know how much I wish I was gay for real
and so so on my deathbed like I I would
probably well I would wait till my kids
were like super old so I can't
traumatize them but I would be like
right as the deathbed was about to
happen I would go like this by the
way I smoke
poles by the way dude oh I smoke
P that would be
the best way to come out oh just y
didn't know I know obviously obviously
we know that I was into chicks but guess
what also smoke Paws oh just
die that's cool man but we knew though
you know like who are the who are the
big pop artists like you're telling
me Taylor Swift never did some gay [__]
she may be a little too old but like the
the Billy ish what is she like 21 like
you don't grow up now and not do gay
[__] at least you know what dude I'm to
LA because I guarantee in Texas they
don't stay still on not even Texas but
like Oklahoma or like Louisiana not
around here boy all you know not around
here boy what you wearing pink they do
that I wear pink you go to the South to
be like what the [__] you wearing that
you're securing your M securing your
masculinity
heterosexuality
it's crazy to be remember what rappers
were the first gays you know because
they would like wear the Pimp [__] like
the Rings the diamond rings the [__]
all the all the pink
stuff you know they they'd like buy bags
that's gay as [__]
Cameron you
know they say Diddy's gay I didn't know
[__] about Diddy up until this year I
knew nothing about Diddy up until this
year my black friends were like oh you
ain't no and I was like what they say oh
Diddy's been on that gay [__] he has
dildos and I'm like
really and he was a bad dude I was like
I didn't know about this they said it
was like R Kelly had no
idea had no idea about that you
know but I guess in a black community
Diddy was known to be a [__] but
whatever dude finally Tupac's getting
his [__] come
upins dude I like the Tupac so much this
is such a funny story I like Tupac so
much that when he died was when I really
started getting into his music you know
1996 and then um they started uh then
then biggie died and then Puff Daddy who
was did Diddy was Puff Daddy back then
he made a uh song called I'll be missing
you it's about Biggie and I always was
like a Tupac fan so I felt like [__]
biggie you know dude me as a 16-year-old
kid white kid locking out I was like
yeah I listen to biggy I wouldn't listen
to biggy because I was a Tupac fan and I
was like loyalty I'm I'm loyal to the
gang you know what I mean like that's
how it would be I'm just [__] sorry
about hey dude I'm loyal to the game
like yeah I might be 16 and I might live
in a [__] nice house in linat and my
dad's a producer director but dude I'm
still loyal to the game you know what
I'm talking
about and so Biggie got killed and then
Diddy was on a um uh an award show and
he was rapping the I'll be missing you
to about bigie remember that song I'll
Be Missing You wow that's actually so
bad if I think about it and um and and
uh Diddy was at odds with Tupac back
then too but Puff Daddy said rest in
peace to everybody and he was going
through the people who died and he said
Tupac sh rest in peace even and I
started [__] balling bro
I'm not loyal to the game so say what
you want about Chris Leah you can't say
he's not loyal to the game so I started
crying and my brother
said what why are you crying it's just a
right before he got finished I said get
the [__] out and he got out dude I was
so loyal to the game my brother thought
he was going to punk me because I was
crying about some [__] that didd he was
saying because he was talking about a
song that was but you know he loved his
best friend who had beef with Tupac but
then at the end he flipped the script
and said recipes to bore I go like this
tears come streaming down my brother
thought he I wasn't loyal to the game he
said why the [__] you doing that I go
like this get the [__] out of my bedroom
he got out of my bedroom and I remain
loyal to the game and I still kind of I
didn't get to have that moment my
brother kind of ruined it but I love my
brother even more than any of that so
I'm Loy to the game in that respect so I
I'm loyal to the
game Lo to the
game
let's see
here I love that
[__]
wow nope don't want
that this guy what is this oh this guy
is on a three-wheel
bike oh Falls for so long dude falls for
so long that's pretty ill that he made
all that but he deserved that at the
end what's up just have a regular bike
you
know the greatest part about this no
sound came from him fell with no sound
when people fall with no sound and they
don't die that is the most amazing [__]
ever um I don't know that's it I think
right
yeah uh subscribe like And subscribe uh
on the Channel dude we love you and
that's it for YouTube if you want the
rest of the episode go to patreon.com /
christalia on this episode The patreon
we talked about the Grand Theft Auto and
the new uh trailer but uh yeah go over
there for just six bucks and there's a
lot of backlogged episodes you can check
them all out immediately once you get
access to it appreciate you go get
tickets to Oxnard that's my next date
and Phoenix and Sacramento and Brea uh
California uh and I appreciate you guys
thank you very much and also right now
stream my special grower die at
chris.com thank you
congratulations
[Music]
[__]